[Music]
that's how I ended up in a body farm the
biggest one in the country
the forensic anthropology Research
Center in South Texas studies how bodies
decompose and why their research helps
law enforcement officers forensic
specialists and scientists figure out
when and how a person died I don't know
if you've ever tried digging holes
especially in Texas it's pretty
difficult thing to do Oh
limestone we have around here totally so
another way that I don't tend to cover
the bodies were throwing refuse on it
you know whatever's around just to try
to conceal the body perpetrators right
murderers
exactly so what this thesis project is
attempting to replicate is in that
instance that you know they throw a
mattress top of the body how that
affects the decomposition rate of these
humans right so if I don't eat my body
here I could help solve a murder from
beyond the grave
what other good deeds could my rotting
corpse do for Humanity
that's that's real okay I am studying
how the clothing will affect vulture
scavenging if clothing like impedes
their ability to access the body they
have a very strong sense of smell are
they just like chin are they watching us
right now they could be
[Music]